boop-boop but now poop has a Netflix
show you try to do with you just explore
ideas that may seem out there or too
scary this is dangerous
how can we really milk the [ __ ] out of
this dangerous unregulated I'll go email
this boy baby how do we milk it how can
we really melt the [ __ ] out of this
30:20 where we just where we exploit
people's fear of Big Pharma in order to
sell them luxury health garbage $300 for
a vial of simple $15 on Amazon pseudo
scientific garbage baby what a way to
kick off the New Year's Netflix promote
goop the goop lab it's funny they they
like portray it as all we're just
talking to a bunch of we're talking to
experts we're talking to scientists guys
don't be full by Gwyneth Paltrow's
lifestyle brand goop they want to
portray themselves and position
themselves as alternatively minded but
scientifically grounded lifestyle
experts but emphasis on the alternative
and no emphasis on the scientific you
can go to gin Gunter's debunking of like
90% of their products you can also go to
goups settlement with the government
sold in boutiques in online goop
wellness products include everything
from expensive crystals to essential
oils saying they can treat ailments like
migraines depression even autoimmune
diseases
but I got to thinking because goop for
all of its pseudoscience has received
pretty lacks coverage I mean like a lot
of people have called it sort of
scientific but almost overshadowing all
of those have been all the like tough
pieces about goop as a lifestyle brand
and it got me thinking like what is
group actually similar to because you
know you might think
from all the coverage the Netflix show
how can we really melt the [ __ ] out of
this the the Jimmy Kimmel appearance
where he pretends to like camel milk
you know I signed up for goop like the
day it started right yeah this is real
this really is camel milk and what is
this like a healthy I think they're
Muslim kamilly yeah doesn't smell bad
all right yeah no yeah this is good you
might think that you know wow she's got
she's got a lot to be she's done a lot
here but guys I would argue actually
wyneth Paltrow's goop line has a lot
more in common with someone that all of
those people I just listed hate the
latest product again we fund ourselves
with water filters and non-gmo seeds
everything is about life everything's
about what you need who says this is all
the crap is in the water table but the
thing is this is taking up a lot of the
room in the water have some kind of
magic property and this is the real
magic right here don't do yourself a
favor do yourself an essential commit to
spend with Infowars Alex Jones I realize
it just just I was thinking like man
what is there is there a similarity
between goop and anyone else like who's
in that huge lifestyle wellness based
and all of a sudden hit me Infowars if
people were cells always like supplement
crap which they put under the name of
also alternative right the doctors don't
know what they're talking about if you
can't pronounce the chemical then it
shouldn't be used in something you're
going to ingest or put on your skin that
that's what it hit me goop is an info
war store without the conspiracy
theories right the same pseudoscience
being peddled just without the
conspiracy theories right Alex Jones has
dr. Edward Group a chiropractor
a chiropractor who functions as a doctor
who does GUP have one of their
contributors is Anthony William a
medical medium who says celery will cure
your diseases now you might be asking
yourself does Anthony William have any
medical credentials are you also a
doctor by trade or no no nip nip
actually um if any William is a medical
medium now what does that mean it means
he's the he's the guy who can see your
diseases because of a spirit that talks
to him and that voice tells me what's
going inside the body so what's
happening you know are you sick
Kim Kardashian promoted this guy his
little woowoo it's just gonna take a
look sure here I'm talking a spirit so
he's going through every organ looking
for the problem whoa
and he also calls himself the only one
I've never heard of another many I'm the
only medical me you're the only medical
yes yes he get me wrong because he's the
only one who could see what he could see
now isn't that nice so yeah goop allows
this guy to regularly post on their
thing hypothesizing the cause of thyroid
problems with his own special theory
despite having no medical training so
there you have it guys
Netflix is producing an Infowars store
ad without the conspiracies but
nonetheless what a shame with that I
guess I'll just leave you with my final
thoughts on
goups goups new documentary how can we
really know the [ __ ] out of this
[Music]